today's report commissioned by Sir
Mark's predecessor makes for very
concerning reading
it's clear that there have been serious
failures of culture leadership and
standards within the Metropolitan Police
that's why Sir Mark rowley's top
priority since becoming commissioner has
been to deliver a plan to turn around
the met and restore confidence in
policing in London
baroness Casey's report finds
deep-seated cultural issues in the force
persistent poor planning and
short-termism a failure of local
accountability insularity and
defensiveness a lack of focus on core
areas of policing including public
protection and she highlights the recent
decline in trust and confidence in the
Met among London's diverse communities
the report underlines the fact that the
Met faces a long road to recovery
improvements must be made as swiftly as
possible but some of the huge challenges
for the organization may take years to
fully address
baroness Casey is clear that Sir Mark
and Deputy Commissioner Lynn Owens
accept the scale of these challenges and
I know this to be true for my own work
with them
I will ensure that the Metropolitan
Police have all the support from central
government they need to deliver on Sir
Mark's pledge of more trust less crime
and high standards every officer in the
force needs to be part of making these
changes happen
as I said as soon as I became Home
Secretary I want all forces to focus
relentlessly on Common Sense policing
that stops crime and keeps the public
safe
this government is already providing the
Metropolitan Police with support to do
just that funding for the force will be
up to 3.3 billion pounds in 2023 a cash
increase of 178 million pounds compared
with 2010 and the force has by far the
highest funding per capita in England
and Wales
as a result of the government's police
uplift program the Metropolitan Police
has more officers than ever before over
000 as of December
the home office is providing funding to
the force to deliver Innovative projects
to tackle drug misuse and county lines
we are working with police and Health
Partners to roll out a national right
care right person model to free up front
line offices to focus on investigating
and fighting crime and ensuring that
people in mental health crises get the
right care from the right agency
at the right time
Mr Speaker it is vital that the
law-abiding public do not face a threat
from the police themselves
those who are not fit to wear the
uniform must be prevented from doing so
and where they are revealed they must be
driven out of the force and face Justice
we've taken steps to ensure that forces
are tackling weaknesses in their vetting
systems I've listened to Sir Mark and
his colleagues and the home office is
reviewing the police dismissals process
to ensure that officers who fall short
of expected standards can be quickly
dismissed